in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Matt
and Brian are with us is it Brian its
Brendan Brinn I can you I'm sorry don't
worry this probably happened before Oh
Matt and Bryn are with us welcome guys
good to have you thanks Dave likewise
thank you and where do you live
we're from Lake Tahoe California Oh fun
beautiful area okay cool and all the way
to Nashville to do your debt free scream
yeah all it was worth it no I love it so
how much debt of you guys paid off
now we've paid off $50,000 in the last
11 months boom just like that love it
yes and making what kind of money during
this time I started out making fifty and
a household income of 85 currently so
how do you get that much of a raise in
one year taking exercise jobs moving
across the country were originally from
Wisconsin I took a job in San Diego and
one more transfer up in Truckee and
joined every minute of it and then moved
you up to Lake Tahoe them yes they're
very cool what do you guys do I'm a
landscape manager and I work with the
handful guys just doing landscaping and
things like that and I'm a travel writer
okay very cool I love it good so what
kind of debt was the $50,000 mostly
student loans medical bills we got a
little thrifty moving to San Diego so we
had a camper that we paid off that we
lived in for a year and a half but yeah
we definitely I definitely made some
progress over the last couple months
that's amazing so what started you on
this journey 11 months ago so when we
got married three years ago we had
talked to each other right before I got
married and Matt was telling me like I
do not want to be in debt this is a
really big priority meaning me not being
debt I was like well no duh like wants
to be in debt that sounds good to me
like sure that's fine so for the first
two years like we tried doing it on our
own and we managed to pay off about ten
thousand bucks each year and then when
we moved out to San Diego our church
there was offering Dave Ramsey it's like
hey I've heard of this guy like and he
starts saying something about like cash
and envelopes and I'm like whatever like
finances that sounds cool let's check it
out so yeah we went to the class and
haven't looked back since and that's
when all of a sudden we were able to
kick it into high gear because we
actually had you know processing the
step and know how to do it and yeah work
our way through it
all of a sudden I when we were able to
pay off the 50 grand because we had the
plan so you kind of cared about the
subject both of you you were okay with
it and Matt was like on it for sure and
but then when you went into the class it
gave you a path yeah well then we just
knew we had spent those first two years
like I mean we were both very passionate
about finances and very much wanted to
be debt-free but every single person we
talked to just we felt like they were
selling us something and they weren't
giving us good direction and we tried
talking to all the usual finance people
that you're supposed to talk to and yeah
it was just kind of usual gimmicks about
like you should use debt to get ahead
and blah blah and all this stuff and so
then when we went to the FPU class it
was like well this is different like I
like this I mean the first time you
walked on stage were like it wasn't
boring and you know I guess it's
interesting to me now looking back on it
all these years later and all the number
of people that have come through the
class Financial Peace University and
I've done what you are doing and I we
often sit around here in our
organization and ask ourselves what is
it that actually works what's the
special sauce and obviously the special
sauce is you guys you're the hero you
you've got to be able to have the want
to to sacrifice but what gave you the
extra spark on you're already hero was
just that you had a path and you it made
it believable is what it sounds like
yeah and I mean I think he's a huge key
of it was surrounding ourself with that
kind of culture and mentality so it
helps that the FPO class has all the
people there who are thinking the same
way you do we lived in Southern
California no one things like that right
so we're surrounded by people who are
driving brand new lease cars and house
they can't afford and you know just
living that kind of lifestyle and solve
sudden having the FPU class then we
listen to the radio show like every
single day and just having someone tell
us you know get up off the couch go do
something with your life like get ahead
you can do this it is possible I mean we
had after a while we were on state aid
we had an unexpected pregnancy you know
we moved we lived in Southern California
we had student loans and people use all
those excuses all the time as reasons
why they can't do it so to have someone
saying no you can do it even though you
have all this stuff like that doesn't
matter and you can fight your way out of
this that was just very empowering to be
so the more we surround ourselves with
that culture and that
mindset the more became our own and
that's actually I was able to become a
writer I'm a stay-at-home mom but I was
listening to you and you kept saying you
know get up off the couch and stop
watching TV and and so my daughter would
take naps I'd be exhausted and all I
wanted to do was just you know chill out
but I was like you know I have two hours
a day that she naps what could I be
doing with my life in those two hours
every single day that I have free and so
within a month I was already getting
paid writing jobs and now I get to work
like this dream job that I never thought
was possible and yet it was because I
took those two hours every single day
and just applied it toward where I
wanted to be eventually that is awesome
thank you and so you're writing writing
travel articles what kind of travel
articles what are you writing about
um I mean mostly right now because we do
have a toddler so I can't really travel
the globe unfortunately but it's just a
lot of research-based stuff so I do a
lot of the content writing for different
vlogs for travel apps and they just need
the pageviews and stuff like that so I
do mostly content writing very good very
cool that's fun though it's rich yeah
and what cut what does something like
that pay most of the articles are like
50 to $100 an article so I mean I can
only do two hours a day but I'm making
around twelve hundred a month and
they're now writing which first day home
mom like it helps out your average at
your average in 50 bucks an hour
probably yeah yeah very good good for
you that's awesome
man you guys are incredible I like you
rock stars man this is so fun alright so
we're gonna talk to the 12 month ago our
two year ago you guys that are listening
and they don't yet know they can do it
but they would like to they don't they
don't really like that but they just
don't know how to get out they're not
sure they can and that used to be you
right yes so what is the secret to
getting out of that what is the process
but what is the thing that did it for
you guys I'd say the biggest thing for
me was not spending that money on other
life events for example we had a bit of
time where we sold our camper we had a
couple of resources kind of all come
together at the same time and we were
looking at a fair chunk of change for
what were used to it was really really
tempting to go buy a house thinking that
we're gonna be taking care of the future
by investing now of sorts not having to
pay you know renting and stuff long term
but instead we took that money and we
chucked it towards debt and I think that
was one of the biggest paradigms
for us there's just realizing that the
best way to get ahead is to take care of
the stuff in the past and just kind of
work towards the future as you go very
cool
good what about you I would say that
it's all going to be worth it and just
yeah it's totally worth every single
it's so short and it seems so short now
looking back like it doesn't seem that
painful and going through it is a lot
harder than when you're standing on the
other side of it and just yeah it's
totally worth it so from the time you
started till the time you finished was
it easier than you thought it was gonna
be when you started or harder than you
thought it was gonna be when you started
it was just boring I mean if you're okay
with being bored it'll be a breeze but
you know it's we just I would say it
marries someone who is your best friend
and who just you can have fun with doing
absolutely nothing yeah because we're
still able to have some of the best
years of our lives
doing nothing yeah well you got eleven
eleven months of that and now you can
you've lived like no one else now you
can live like no one else there you go
okay pronounce your name for me one more
time Bryn Bryn I didn't want to mess it
up twice I apologize okay
so Matt and Bryn fifty thousand dollars
paid off in 11 months making fifty to
eighty five thousand dollars a year
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
way to go you guys just like that that's
how it's done man I love that
you